ich habe kein aktuelles thema
mitgebracht weil ich auch der meinung
bin dass die wirklich wichtigen
änderungen oft gar nicht diesen sie sich
von heute auf morgen angeben oder
aktuell sind ganz langfristige
entwicklungen über die wir beim prinzip
viel zu wenig reden und ich möchte
darüber eine änderung reden und zwar
dass die armut auf der ganzen welt in
den letzten jahrzehnten so stark
zurückgegangen ist wie noch nie in der
menschheitsgeschichte also noch vor 40
jahren da haben 43 prozent der menschen
auf der welt in extremer armut gelebt
heute weniger als zehn prozent oder ich
gehe noch mal ein bisschen weiter zurück
bevor der kapitalismus entstand also
sagen also 1820 da haben noch 90 prozent
der menschen in extremer armut gelebt 90
prozent auf der welt heute weniger als
zehn prozent und das ist finde ich eine
ganz bemerkenswerte entwicklung über wer
mit zu wenig spricht und ja ich bin ein
großer anhänger vom kapitalismus jemand
neues buch da hab ich auch hoch halten
hier der antikapitalisten ja die zellen
irrtümer der anti kapitalisten und ja
das ist ein großer irrtum großer
ethikrat dass man sagt also der
kapitalismus ist für hunger und armut
auf der welt verantwortlich nein ich
sage genau das gegenteil der
kapitalismus ist dafür verantwortlich
dass die armut so stark zurückgegangen
ist wie noch nie in der geschichte und
das wissen die meisten menschen nicht
und darüber wird nicht geredet und
deswegen eigentlich sollte man ja
erstens stimmig hinzu also das stimmt
ganz sicher ich glaube ihnen auch alle
zahlen los muss ich einschränkend sagen
die menschen leben in den statistiken
und den zahlen sondern die empfinden
armut also wenn das gibt es heute
zweifellos selbst in deutschland dass
menschen mit jedem euro rechnen müssen
merkt man ja gerade jetzt wo die
energiepreise steigen die preise
generell steigen da kriegt man mal
gelegentlich sieht man mal oder liest
man mal was leute viel geld zur
verfügung haben verfügbares einkommen
für lebensmittel und andere dinge und
das ist schon ziemlich
schockierend ehrlich gesagt da gibt es
sehr viele denen es schlecht geht im
prinzip haben sie aber recht ich möchte
kein anderes wirtschaftssystem haben ich
fühle mich in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft wohl und da muss man an
einigen dingen noch arbeiten aber
wir sollten ein bisschen nicht nicht so
sehr auf die zahlen schauen sondern auf
die menschen die in ihnen leben ich
frage an welchen parametern machen sie
es heißt also es ist ja immer dieses
ringen darum was ist eigentlich
fortschritt nicht
folglich wird auch bei uns die
diskussion so an als hätten wir gar
keinen fortschritt und dann kann man
natürlich von lebenserwartung über
zahngesundheit bis bis zu was leistet
was auch immer verfeinerung der
lebensweise verbesserung der
öffentlichen räume also sehr viel
aufzählen was selbstverständlich
unendlich viel besser geworden ist aber
was sind für diesen armuts begriff die
die parameter also ja also sagt zum
wasser zugang zu bildung hunger so gut
das sind definition von der von der
weltbank dass bestimmte kriterien messen
aber ich wüsste man das nicht so
abstrakt das soll diesmal am konkreten
beispiel erklären also china ich war oft
in china und was viele menschen nicht
wissen noch ende der 50er jahre sind 540
millionen menschen 45 millionen hungern
und am größten sozialistischen
experimente der menschheitsgeschichte
umgekommen ja warm aus sogenannter
großer sprung nach vorne also ich halte
vorträge überall auf der welt über diese
themen fragt ob du die leute wer hat das
wert in der schule was gehört von maus
großen sprung nach vorne wo 45 millionen
menschen umgekommen sie haben sie was
gehört in der schule ich versage in der
synthese weil leider dann wärst du dich
genau ja ist ja wunderbar findet findet
heute aber es ist halt ganz oft nicht
der fall und jetzt nur noch mal eine
zahl noch
1981 haben 88 prozent der chinesen
extreme armut gelebt heute ist weniger
als ein prozent warum war deng xiaoping
dann irgendwann nach maos tod
privateigentum geführt hat einen füttert
marktwirtschaft eingeführt hat ja und er
will ja niemand mehr zurück zur zurzeit
nur weil die menschen nach gleicher
waren und aber ich kann das nur ein
bisschen genauer also kann man das
totalitäre system china überhaupt zum
beispiel mit deutschland vergleichen und
die zweite frage die hat aber jetzt
schon vollgas ja auch gesagt gehabt wir
sind demokratie wäre wahrscheinlich
schon auch ganz natürlich bin jetzt
keinen fürsprecher von china das ist ein
totalitäres system ich rede jetzt nur
ein von der wirtschafts form also wir
müssen ja ein bisschen zwischen der
politik und wirtschaft und erscheint und
bei der wirtschaft muss man sagen da ist
er einfach die einführung von
marktwirtschaft im privaten eigentum hat
den chinesen sehr gut getarnt übrigens
deutschen auch wenn china nicht also als
handelspartner hätten ja dann weiß ich
wie es in deutschland heute auch ja ist
vermutlich das land in dem der
kapitalismus am ungebremste ssten wirkt
also also erst mal ich war ja da und hat
mit den vertretern auf einem
rangierbahnhof
in china der hat mir gesagt also wir
sind hier die letzten verteidiger des
kapitalismus bei uns glaubt kein mensch
mehr an karl marx alle das muss man
sagen leider ändert sich das im moment
ein bisschen wieder also es gibt so ein
index der ökonomischen freiheit und da
hat china im letzten jahr ganz stark
abgenommen und ich bin auch befreundet
mit einem ökonomen also von der peking
universität und der sagt mir leider geht
es im moment wieder ein bisschen in die
entgegengesetzte richtung das wäre ganz
schlimm weil der ganze fortschritte in
china gemacht hat er sagte er hätte es
war nicht wegen dem staat oder trotzdem
statt und das verstehen aber hier fielen
denn wenn sie das ist ja das eigentlich
dass der kern ihrer botschaft ja wenn
man das an hunger misst und am extremen
elend nur menschen umkommen durch
krankheiten und hunger dann das ist ganz
sicher besser geworden und das mache ich
jetzt immer nur als nebenbemerkung wir
nehmen ja jetzt auch zur kenntnis dass
ich wusste das schon lange aber die ist
das große problem nimmt zur kenntnis
dass auch in der ukraine durch stalin
millionen von menschen verhungert
worden lassen sind es habe ich ein
bisschen schräg ausgedrückt stalin
millionen von menschen umgebracht durch
hunger und das war gezielte politik um
die ukraine die für bürgerlich gehalten
würden bauern kulaken die land besaßen
die mussten umgebracht werden also 80
wir denken aber hunger heute an afrika
logischerweise aber der hunger auch groß
ist aber
80 prozent der menschen die bei
hungersnöten umgekommen sind waren in
china und in russland gewesen da war es
auch was viele menschen nicht wissen
aber herr doktor doktor titel mannes ihm
sei es nämlich selbst angesprochen das
ist ein großes problem dass in unseren
schulen ja viele so auch so sehr relativ
linke lehrer dann gern mal sozialkunde
unterrichtet dass dort den schülern den
jungen menschen eigentlich überhaupt
nicht mehr vermittelt wird teilweise
ganz im gegenteil was die grundlagen
unseres wohlstands hier sind und wie
wertschöpfung stattfindet und so etwas
dann kommen dann irgendwie so kleine
linke dann irgendwie bei raus und gut
und manche schüler haben auch eine
gewisse irgendwie widerspruchsgeist
vielleicht aber das halte ich für ein
großes problem es bräuchte eigentlich
wie so was wie ein fach wirtschaft in
der schule oder so es muss den leuten
vermietet werden worauf eigentlich wie
wo das alles herkommt was uns ausmacht
nur ohne freiheit und demokratie
funktioniert das ja nach unserem
verständnis nicht wirklich deswegen ist
china eben immer ein problematisches
beispiel und ich würde ihnen was die
wirtschaftskenntnisse angeht total recht
geben aber auf der anderen seite ist
weiß auch kein mensch für unser
politisches system funktioniert die
allermeisten leute wissen nicht den
unterschied zwischen erst und
zweitstimme und ehrlich gesagt seitdem
dort ist ein verfassungsgerichtsurteil
verstehe ich also auch nicht mehr ganz
wie die mandate für bundestag noch
ausgeglichen werden nur dass der immer
grösser wird dadurch aber insofern also
auch die kenntnisse der neueren
deutschen geschichte ich meine also sind
wir sind doch so bis zum dritten reich
gekommen und und dann vielleicht noch
also sowieso die gründung der
bundesrepublik so eben gerade noch und
dann war's das und die darbietung saison
vielleicht genau ddr kommt gar nicht
habe ich alles vielleicht auch lehrer
abhängig zb wenn ich das jetzt hier höre
muss ich ja ich glaube ich danach als
meine karte meiner ehemaligen
geschichtslehrer schreiben ich hatte das
alles im geschichtsunterricht wo war das
dorf näher aber erweisen sagen will ist
also mich ich glaube dass es auch an
engagierten lehrern gibt zum beispiel
überhaupt keine ahnung von chemie und
physik und denken immer hätte ich mal
spannendere lehrer gehabt wird sich
vielleicht wegen sie grundkenntnisse
also dass immer das so ich bin ich
glaube muss man dann nicht eher sagen
vielleicht müssen lehrer besser
ausgebildet werden auch vielleicht mehr
geld verdienen weil ich glaube es hängt
auch immer mittlerweile angekommen ist
er stunden also ist es gibt ja keine
wirtschaft es gibt manchmal nur noch
eine stunde geschichte also ich habe da
eine ganz andere wirtschaft in der
schule für mich klasse aber wenn der
lehrer dass unterricht unterhalt ist
nicht so viel davon weil der lehrer der
hat doch nie angerührt angesagt mit der
wirtschaft erst die schule gegangen dann
ist an die uni gegangen dann ist er
wieder zurück in die schule getragen für
eine wirtschaft seite nie was
mitgekriegt also ich wäre für was
anderes dass man sagt wir laden jede
woche einmal ein unternehmer ein in die
schule der erzählt wie er die firma
gegründet hat die firma aufgebaut hat ja
und erzählt was über unternehmertum
begeistert dann vielleicht junge
menschen für unternehmertum das kann
teilnehmer besser als die lehrer einmal
zurück zu ihrer anfangs these die sender
in der tat schon spannend ja auch wenn
man dann natürlich drüber lange
diskutieren kann sie sagen ja die armut
zurückgedrängt worden und zwar auf dem
globus generell ja auch in der dritten
welt das so genannte afrika überall
wir haben aber trotzdem ich bin ich aber
nicht relativieren wir haben große
fluchtbewegungen und so weiter aber ich
will es anders sagen wir lernen doch wir
lesen über all die armen werden immer
ärmer und die reichen werden immer
reicher das ist doch eine zu einer
gebetsmühlenhaft formulierung geworden
in deutschland
wobei man dann schon mal untersuchen
muss wie wird denn armut überhaupt
definiert was ist die die grundlage
einer solchen statistik aber
sie aber sie tun sie an ihrem buch die
die leute müssen um sich mit dem thema
zu beschäftigen mit dieser general
formel die reichen immer reicher die
haben immer müssen die andere daten
haben die dem widersprechen damit man
überhaupt diskussionsfähig wird deshalb
ist ihre these wichtig das finde ich
toll oder nena
bestimmt auch irgendwo klar die reichen
werden immer reicher karte auch in
letzter zeit aber das ist ja nichts
verkehrt dass das ist ja nichts
schlechtes das sind für mich zwei seiten
einer medaille
also weil ich vorhin über china geredet
habe ich habe gesagt wie ist die zahl
der armen zurückgegangen aber
gleichzeitig ist die zahl der
milliardäre so stark gestiegen wie in
keinem anderen hat also heute gibt es so
viele milliardäre in china wie in den
usa und übrigens in peking mehr als new
york was viele leute gar nicht wissen ja
das heißt also das sind zwei seiten
einer medaille
und das ist ja dieser nullsummen glaube
denn über die leute an die denken ja der
arme ist nur weil der reiche ihm was
weggenommen hat dann werden wir diese
ganze entwicklung gar nicht verständlich
also heute gibt es fünf mal mehr
milliardäre auf der welt als noch vor 20
jahren aber die armut ist gleichzeitig
gesunken